-But this is interesting
because --
´Cause I think
there´s this issue now
is the Democratic Party
sort of hoping for, you know,
something to fall from
the heavens to fix this
and not focusing enough
on being a strong party.
Do you think the focus
needs to be on the mid-terms,
or do you think
that is a lost cause?
-Not -- Oh. We only have to flip
24 of the Republican seats.
There´s 435 seats in the House.
To get the House back,
we only need 24.
In the Senate,
we only need 3.
Are we that much of
a loser group of people?
That we can´t get 3?
I mean -- Here.
Let me give you the statistic.
Most people don´t realize this.
In the last seven
presidential elections,
the Democrat has won the
popular vote in six of them.
Six of the last seven.
The Republicans have only won
the popular vote once
in the last 30 years,
once since 1988.
The American people
want the Democrat.
They want the liberal agenda.
They believe women should be
paid the same as men.
They believe that there´s
climate change.
They believe in
stronger gun-control laws.
That´s our fellow Americans.
And yet we hold no power!
-And you point this out in
your show, that Donald Trump --
You need everybody to admit --
That´s the first step, is that
Donald Trump outsmarted us.
-You have to say, "Donald Trump
outsmarted us all,"
and then deal with the throw-up
that´s in your mouth.
-Yeah.
But I think that´s fair to say.
-It´s the truth.
-You have to give credit there.
-I mean, generally, in a game,
the person who wins the game
obviously was better
at least that day.
-Yeah.
-And he figured it out.
He was smart enough to --
to convince 8 million
Obama voters to vote for him.
-Which is still -- yeah.
-He was smart enough to convince
the majority of white women
to vote for him.
53% of white women
voted for him.
Smart enough --
He was smart enough to know
where the state of Wisconsin was
and go there.
-Go there.
That´s a big deal. Yeah.
-And I think that he --
You know, he knew
the right things to say
because he was a TV star.
He knew how to
communicate on TV.
You keep it simple, you know?
You and I are gonna do
eight minutes here.
We´re not gonna do
a six-hour harangue
on the Emoluments Clause
of the U.S. Constitution.
-No.
We´ll keep it simple for TV.
-Right?
-You obviously are very --
One of the things
you´ve railed against
is the Republican --
or the Conservative
belief system.
-Yes.
-But that is
an actual belief system.
Do you prefer that
to what Donald Trump is?
-I actually -- I actually do.
People are worried that,
well, if we get rid of Trump,
we´ll have Pence.
I say, no, don´t be
worried about that.
Pence actually
believes in things.
We can have the great debate
with him.
He believes in gay conversion.
He believes gay people
can be converted.
He believes that Adam and Eve
rode on dinosaurs
6,000 years ago.
But we can have
that debate with him.
And because
the majority of Americans
don´t want the Republicans in
charge, we can win the debate
´cause most Americans
will agree with us.
With Trump, he doesn´t --
He believes --
His belief system
is Donald J. Trump.
That´s it.
-Yeah.
-That´s all he believes in,
is himself
and what kind of money he can
make for himself and his family.
And that´s
a much more dangerous,
I think, situation to be in.
You´ve got him out there in
Bedminster, you know, last week.
Bedminster, New Jersey.
Threatening nuclear war
from a golf club.
And I know you´ve made jokes
about this here,
but it´s kind of like --
Seriously, anybody who lives
in the New York area,
has any good idea ever come out
of Bedminster, New Jersey?
-Yeah.
-Certainly not
blowing up the world.
-No, you wouldn´t want that
to come out of Bedminster.
Well, congratulations
on the show.
And I know it´s going
until October. Is that right?
-Yeah.
Until the end of October.
I´m having a -- It´s a great --
I want people to come see this,
´cause it´s very --
something I can´t do
in the movies.
It´s live. It´s in the room.
It´s different every night.
And it´s a piece of theater
that I´ve written for
the times in which we live.
And I welcome people to come.
And I made it part of my deal --
´cause you know
how expensive Broadway is.
-Yeah, it´s very expensive.
-That the whole balcony
is 29 bucks.
-Oh, that´s fantastic.
-So people could come.
So it´s --
-Man of the people.
-If you don´t have 29 bucks,
I´ll help you out!
-Michael Moore, everybody.
"The Terms of My Surrender"
at the Belasco on Broadway.